[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
higher pen show
today we are going to be talking about
the market
bitcoin is finally back up at 46k which
is pretty insane
so i'm very excited to jump in but
before we do this is of course
um powered by icon plus they are a vc
firm um
it is also sponsored by block five so a
huge thank you to them because obviously
without them i wouldn't be able to have
these amazing conversations
um and before we jump on and bring
today's guest in
um a quick shout out actually to compass
mining because
this particular episode is um sponsored
by them and
this is basically the company that makes
bitcoin mining accessible for
everyone all you have to do is just buy
a machine pick a hosting facility
and let them do the work so if you want
to start mining today then just head to
compassmining.io
pretty great given bitcoin is very very
expensive to mine so they make it
accessible
so that is fun all right so today's
guest is danny scott
the ceo of the bitcoin exchange compass
sorry coin corner what's so much going
on right now
coin corner welcome danny how are you
doing hi leah i'm good thank you
hi so how's yourself yeah i'm good i'm
good
so for those that don't know much about
you i do want to just
start by giving more background before
we jump into bitcoin
um because you guys are a uk exchange
um this is such a us market so tell us a
little bit about
you and of course coin corner yep
um so we yeah we are as you mentioned
there sort of
a uk focus we're based in the allen man
um
we've been around founded in 2014 um
primary audience market is uk um and
always been the uk focus
um predominantly again focus on bitcoin
um rather than go down the exchange
route we're more of a um
brokerage style coinbase-esque uh
company um so again it's a massive focus
on bitcoin uh for us here so we are more
at the bitcoiners which you can see the
cushion to the
corner of me there apologies if people
are walking past in the background
um we all sat in our office today um
so yeah i'm um one of the i'm the ceo
and co-founder of coin corner
uh we were founded back in 2014 as i
mentioned there
uh prior to that i was a software
developer by trade and then
um kind of found come across bitcoin
through
uh various ways as you always do and i
think you hear about it a couple of
times before you really pay attention
and started mining back in 2012-13 times
um played around with that for a while
um until the electricity costs here in
the island mine got too expensive
um you have an interesting story i want
to hear more about that because i know
you have a really interesting story
about that
okay the mining mine inside um yeah so
yeah so we
started mining let's say back in in 2012
13 times
um it was myself and one of the
co-founders of coin corner and we were
mining in his garage initially
um so we were at first kind of just
hobbyist playing around didn't really
know much about it we had a software
development company at the time
um and we're both techies both geeks
both into that side of things
um so we spent probably about
two or three months building up the farm
and kind of getting bigger and bigger
and
more hardware as we was adding to it um
and then it started blowing his
electrics in his house because it was in
his garage
uh so we blew his electrics quite a few
times there um
and had to keep scaling back to for some
part and then eventually
we decided to jump into a warehouse and
start mining in a warehouse
um we moved out of his garage and went
into a warehouse um
back in i think that might have been end
of 2013 14 i can't quite remember the
time and stuff
um and then from there we scaled up to
a fairly decent ish size um but then
very quickly
asics kind of dominated the scene at
that point anyway
and kind of killed off from an electric
cost perspective it just wasn't worth it
was over the time so
uh being both software developers by
trade we decided to pivot into the the
bitcoin exchange side
there was not really much competition in
the uk um
it wasn't a great mod it was it was
obviously very early days
uh and the on-ramp for bitcoin exchanges
in the uk was was lacking
um so we kind of jumped into that side
and we wanted to stay in the industry at
that point because we was interested
and we kind of moved that way excuse me
um so yeah
i'm sorry yeah no i'm just gonna say
your mining story i know we've spoken
about it before but it always
blows my mind i just i can't believe
you know the electricity was just
blowing and things were just
it's just crazy would you ever mind
bitcoin again or are you just
focused on the exchange right now i'm
focused on the exchange
right now but um i'd never say never i
think the
mining side was certainly an
easier business model um
but i think that was kind of we managed
to during the mining part of the process
we managed to gain
banking relationships because of what we
were doing it wasn't quite as high risk
as the exchange piece so
once we pivoted to the exchange you
start seeing lots of new
uh eventful problems that you come
across banking being
um probably the main one um
that we moved into so yeah maybe in the
future uh it's something i keep an eye
on something that
in the element again the electricity
costs are too expensive for the most
part but
um maybe if we have more the renewable
sustainable energy that um
we do have certain things here that do
that we have a lot of wind farms around
the island uh so it's certainly an
option but it's uh maybe a bigger
project than
uh it can take on right now yeah i know
you're doing some interesting things
with
um the isle of the authorities and the
isle of man or the government and the
isle of man i think that's kind of what
you refer to them as
um but but we'll get to that but before
i do i think
what's what really struck me about your
exchange was that you are heavily
bitcoin focused and it's such
a um there's so it's quite a tribal
market isn't it you know the way people
feel about different cryptocurrencies
and
you've chosen to be heavily bitcoin
focused so what does that mean for you
guys and why did you decide to do that
um a number of reasons i think
um the the main reason i guess
myself and some of the other other
members of the team
we've always kind of we do a lot of
research into the industry and you know
i've
been around the industry quite some
years now um and especially in the
earlier days we've played around with
creating our own coin and playing around
with them sort of things we never really
launched and did anything it was just
more of a tech
interest and playing around with the
concept um
from that point i've always given the
time of day to altcoins as in to
research and understand them and
understand their
bigger picture in the world and how they
fit and how they're seen but
um bitcoin for me is still the
de facto cryptocurrency should we call
it and bitcoin is king
um but it has the long-term
sustainable model shall we call it
um altcoins necessarily most of them
um are not really they're kind of
focused on
various niches if not trying to just
clone bitcoin at which point it's just
just not worth let's
not go down that route with a minute um
but
the way i've always seen it as bitcoin
will be the long-term one the rest of
them are still just a complete gamble in
terms of their niches and whether they
find a market fit which they may do in
the future but
um right now it's just not there um so
there was that angle of you know i
believe in bitcoin's long-term
um lifespan so at which point you know
you want to focus your business model
and your business around
the long term rather than the short term
um
the other side of that is kind of focus
on doing one thing well
and where you have all the bitcoin
exchanges like your binance
and um even cracking and
um you know even bit stamping the likes
they all have expanded into they're more
of a trading focus platform where we've
always tried to hit retail and
keep it a bit simpler um with that in
mind
they've all got trading as tools so
they've got
graphs and all the numbers and all that
side of things
we've stuck to a more simpler method um
and
trying to differentiate ourselves from
these guys you know binance have added
every coin you can think of these days
um why would we try and compete with
them
when we feel as well and we believe that
then
the the certain coins they're adding or
the products that are adding they're
more of a short term gain for a long
term
loss so we're looking at maybe a
short-term loss for a long-term gain
um so we're in it for the long term
rather than just trying to get in get
out with
various altcoins um which i think
everyone
kind of i imagine everybody would agree
they're kind of pumping dumb pest style
coins which are not really a long term
viable
um so it was kind of there is a number
of reasons of why we've tried to focus
around that
um and trying to build out bitcoins
infrastructure and help with that
which is what we tried to introduce in
going corner with various products built
around bitcoin
um obviously with lightning with the
cashback and uh the checkout
um everything is focused around bitcoin
um being the core product
yeah let's talk about that for a sec
because you've got the
cashback which is really cool i actually
downloaded the
browser extension um last week so i need
to try that
um but that is really cool because it
really just that's like a direct
competitor to lolly right but lolly
isn't available
in the uk um so
i guess just like my question is why do
you think the uk scene just isn't quite
what we see in the u.s like in the us
everything is just booming you know
they've got conferences
they've got um most the companies that
you and i speak with are all us-based
why is the uk just so behind in that
sense like it just doesn't want to
innovate does it
yeah i think i think there's um is it
does feel that way um and it does often
feel that way
and even for us on the island man we're
here with um
very small population and you know i can
we can literally every morning from our
window just over there we can see the uk
and
you know it's right there in front of us
so we're at stone's throw away
um even we feel distanced from the uk
sometimes even though you know we
kind of sit underneath it but then
obviously from the uk point you know we
feel distance even
further from the us because yeah it
seems to all be happening in the us
um i think a big part of it is it's
definitely
silicon valley style so you know bitcoin
is a tech industry and it's a growing
uh sort of booming tech industry and
that always comes or that's always
driven from
the silicon valley side of things um you
know money from
vcs is all there and um there's a lot
more money a lot more skill sets a lot
more
uh talent should we say around silicon
valley or historically has been
i appreciate now there's a bit of a mass
exodus from the um
so it tech and new brand new booming
industries always kind of drive from
that side of things and move them
further afield
so it certainly is always a us driven
industry and i think that's what we're
seeing with with uh bitcoin now on the
crypto side
um i think obviously the us has a much
bigger population
uh 330 40 million is it um you know the
uk has got 64 million i think is it
around that something like that
so yeah we're kind of when you think put
things like that into perspective you
know it kind of makes sense that there's
it feels like there's more people over
there involved there is more people but
the
percentage-wise uh i'm not sure of the
the portions
uh actually no it's probably true the uk
was about four percent i think that we
know
of uk people population that
own bitcoin and i think the us is at
something like is it 16
or something yeah i remember that um so
yeah they're a little bit more
um advanced and ahead of us um as are
some other countries but then obviously
other countries are
way behind um so yeah it's definitely
the uk would like to drive
more products as you're saying they're
like lolly in the us um with the cash
back
and they were kind of first movers i'm
not too sure if there's many other
competitors there on that particular
product
um at the minute but again they had uk
we were i think first if not
i think there was one other but i'm not
too sure if they're still running kind
of a one-man band
um and it is early days and we're trying
to drive the market by bringing these
products and introducing these products
um which hopefully we can do over time
uh
which is it takes
um it just it takes a long time and it
takes time to build
and drive these products whereas i think
the industry feels like it moves really
quick when you've had
altcoins icos um nfts you know
all of these things they come and go
very quickly and
it feels like such a fast-paced industry
and it is but then the real
sort of substance products like keeping
the cash back side
um there's a real substance to that
there is already cash back companies in
the uk in the us that are not bitcoin
related but they do
the same product effectively but give
you gbp or us dollar back
and there's a real substance there in a
real market um but you know that will
take time to grow and
um people to adopt it i think
i think like what what concerns me is
all the hostility towards bitcoin um and
just the and cryptocurrencies are large
really um i mean i know the us obviously
have the infrastructure bill right now
um which they're dealing with which is a
big deal
um you know and the uk has gone pretty
hard
on cryptocurrency regulation i know the
fca which for those who aren't
um english that's our financial conduct
authority
they have started i think it's an 11
million pound
campaign to warn people about
cryptocurrency i mean for me that money
would be much better spent
um on financial literacy that's another
topic um
so so why why do you think they're going
so hard on it you know
do you think this poses a threat to
anything
you know let's talk about like finance
as an example you know they've had
they've now had their payments blocked
from hsbc
nat west barclays those are three major
banks
have you guys faced any issues like that
yep
um i guess coming back to yeah the u.s
thing i'll come back to the yeah
at least in a minute but the us um with
the infrastructure build
been trying to keep up to date with that
um it's u.s politics and it's you know
it's absolutely chaos
um it's for me highlighting um to the
world a little bit how
u.s politics is done and how these bills
are
introduced is just not right there's
something fundamentally wrong with
the system of how they do that um there
seems to have been obviously this
massive kick off about the crypto side
of things there and trying to get that
part of the bill through
um or the bill as a whole through but
getting held up because of this
as far as i'm aware this bill has been
has been
being held up because of the crypto side
so there's a big push back there
within this infrastructure bill there's
lots of other industries in there but
maybe you know they're not as effective
or
affected by it or maybe they just don't
have that community there that'll push
back and
delay the bill like it has them um
for me i don't understand why they don't
just define
broker you know it's all come down to
this one definition of the broker
um they need to just define broker as a
bitcoin exchange effectively somewhere
where you can trade
cryptocurrency for a fiat currency and
that's
the definition done and the rest of the
if they want to come and come back later
in catch
you know they can't really catch miners
and node um people running nodes and
things but you know if they want to try
and look to that or even the d5 side
come back to that in in time and make
them amendments um
rather than the other way around which
they've gone up the way around by looks
of it
um so yeah it's just is that
incompetence though in your opinion or
is that like
actual genuine um disliking
towards it i don't know how much of a
conspiracy
needs to wear today i'm not sure um i
think they've
they've certainly i don't want to call
them
people it's easy to call somebody
incompetent um from the outside and not
looking sit in their position of what
they're doing
um not defending them in any way
whatsoever because what they've done is
terrible but
um they you know for something like that
they should have already reached out to
the industry
experts or the industry as a whole and
gathered feedback
before they introduce it to the bill
which they haven't done um so that you
know they should be doing that and
taking the advice and not just you know
the advice is being given now by the
industry but they're
still just ignoring it and trying to get
the bill through and now that's part of
they want to get the bill through as
quick as they can because of x y and z
or other external reasons
outside of our industry um so it's kind
of like that is politics in the us so
it's hard to to comment on whether
that's incompetence or whether that's
rushing something through um or on the
other side of it
are they trying to attack the industry
and attack um
maybe a little maybe not i don't feel
like they're trying to attack
bitcoin try to be careful while i say
here okay
i won't hold you to anything i don't
think they're trying to attack bitcoin
as such and
um exchanges miners things like that i
think
maybe you could argue that they're
trying to attack more of the defy
side of things where they may start to
realize that they can't
control certain areas of that um
although
i appreciate most of the d5 these days
if not all is pretty much centralized in
some manner
um so there's always a central point of
um choke that they can
go to if need be um but yeah maybe that
that's a
an angle for them they can't figure out
how to regulate d5 so you know
put a tax bill around it and um require
anybody involved in d5 to report to the
irs
meaning that he'll probably scare most
people off because they won't want to
have to deal with that
and the consequence of not reporting
them things so could be a tactical move
um in that respect i kind of don't
really know um
enough about u.s politics maybe to um
understand if this is normal law or this
is out of the ordinary
so yeah wait and see i guess i can't
imagine the uk
and and following on coming back to the
uk i can't really imagine the uk at the
minute
particularly starting to look to
introduce something like this
i appreciate that there will be um tax
reporting
requirements for bitcoin exchanges at
some point down the line to hmrc which
i'm sure that will come
i appreciate that hmrc already reached
out was that last year or the year
before to
a lot of uk exchanges asking them to
report their clients
um but it was um again it's not a
requirement at the minute
that will come in time i'm sure um by
the minute they're just
i think the uk playing a bit catch up
with the regulatory perspective
um we've got the crypto register coming
or here
for some part um and then i can i'm sure
we can see eventually
um so the crypts are registered just
gives kind of an oversight of
aml um on crypto businesses
uh it isn't effectively regulated
um so they're just you're just
registered with the fca rather than
regulated by the fca
um so eventually i imagine they'll
slowly migrate that into a regulated by
the fca which means they can you know
come and spot check you whenever they
feel like it and have more of an
oversight into your operations
um so that will come in time but i think
at the minute this is just a stepping
stone for them to
kind of gather them crypto businesses
into one and try and
um weed out the bad bad players i guess
i think people know like the you know
authorities governments central banks
know the threat that bitcoin poses and
the
industry as a whole poses and i feel
that they don't like
it so for me i do feel that it is
somewhat intentional
um did you see the news about um the eu
wanting to
eventually ban anonymous cryptocurrency
addresses
yeah yeah yeah i mean number is that
possible
i mean what's up what's going on with
that um
that was the the wallet one wasn't there
they were trying to yeah yeah
um they it's kind of all based up so
faffer which is the
um global financial authority should we
call it
uh they're the guys that try and um come
at a global perspective for the
financial world and try and
uh dictate to um fat for registered
countries which
most of the world or a lot of the world
is um or fall under faffer
um fatfur don't make laws or rules but
they
kind of dictate what the world should do
and they'll put
um you know their creator guidance
should we call it and they put guidance
in place to say right you need to act
and do these things
and then it's for the countries to
actually follow fafsa's guidelines and
introduce them into law and regulation
um but what we've seen obviously the
last couple of years with fatfer is they
are trying to push certain
um cryptocurrency guidance out there
and part of that guidance um was
something called the travel rule
and this these these are still going on
in the background this is still
happening
um but part of the travel rule um was
effectively meaning that if
a bitcoin transaction left say coin
corner
and it was going to coinbase for example
we would need to know it's going to
coinbase and we would need to pass the
information
over to coinbase of who this customer is
that's done the withdrawal from coin
corner
to coinbase and let them know that it's
you know uh
joe blogs has sent 0.2 bitcoins to you
guys
um and they'd confirm receipt um and
backwards and forwards so if
vice versa from coinbase to coin corner
do the same thing
there's nothing out there at the minute
technically that makes that possible
um so there is people trying to build
software that'll be middle tiers that'll
kind of allow that and make that
transaction happen
um you know there is uh opportunities
for things like
lightning where um lightning you can
create
you create an invoice and you can create
and attach a message to it so
theoretically if somebody sends
lightning payment from coin corner to
coinbase
um then we would be able to pass the
coinbase and be able to display that
this is a coinbase lightning invoice and
we would know it is so then we could
pass the
customer's information across in the
lightning invoice to them
um as well so it could be vice versa so
there is certain things in there that
are slowly coming from a technical
technological perspective but they are
still years away and getting
all the exchanges up to scratch and
integrated
coming back to what you were talking
about there sorry on the yeah
with wallets and trying to ban private
wallets on that side
um that kind of came off a little bit of
the back of the
the fat for the travel rule and trying
to it's not like they're trying to ban
bitcoin and ban
um personal wallets it's that they're
trying to help close
close the loop a little bit should we
call it in terms of um
making sure that when we send so
customer of ours sends bitcoin out of
our system we know whether it's going to
their personal wallet or whether it's
going to an another exchange
so we can make sure it's kind of like
how the banking world works i guess at
the minute
and when you send a banking transaction
it goes to
another bank and you know you know
there's a system in place there to pass
the information of who it's going to and
where it's coming from
and so on um so they're just trying to
wrap something i guess the legacy
regulation
around crypto at the minute um and
that's kind of the
the battle i guess where we're at or in
um
and trying to figure out you know how do
we i would love to be the whole you know
we don't need that
side of the regulation and we don't need
them um sort of rules around us and we
don't need fat food
to be dictating x y and z um which you
know yeah
on some some part no we don't but at the
same time it's going to come
so it's going to happen regardless of
what we want and whether we want it
and so we need to make sure we're
meeting in the middle which is similar
to this infrastructure bill in the u.s
it's happening regardless of whether
people want it or not so you need to
sort of that's the part of the lobbying
there and trying to communicate with
the regulators and um you have to make
them
see sense for some of it and um find a
happy medium
uh in between um so yeah the eu side
then they were never looking
to ban private wallets um it was more of
a
stone towards maybe the travel rule side
of things and the flapper rules that are
looking to come in um we saw uh
netherlands with the netherlands about a
year ago they introduced the law
basically they introduced that same
thing which was the travel rule so okay
um dutch exchanges could
um if you were looking to when their
customers was trying to withdraw bitcoin
if it was going to their private wallet
they had to prove provide like a
screenshot of evidence of where it was
going to and so
they then did take that to court and
they won their their court battle
i think back in march it might have been
this year um
which then has allowed them to scrap
that off now because it just wasn't
workable for the companies
and it stifles innovation which is
exactly what it's done um yeah and we
went through
um the crazy thing i was talking to a
couple of a couple of the guys
um from the u.s side i'm from the the
dutch side when this was all happening
because it's happened in the us as well
as there was talk about
back in november i think last year um
with a similar rule
um and we actually had this exact same
thing in the isle of man
um back in 2016 i think it was
and we worked with the regulators here
and explained everything showed them you
know we actually integrated
a automated process for
a customer when they wanted to withdraw
their bitcoin they had to sign
and it was going to a personal wallet
they had to sign a transaction on the
uh sorry they had to sign a message on
their address to prove that they had the
ownership of that address
and so we automated that in our system
and did it as a try as a trial
um not because we wanted to it's because
the regulators were asking us to
somehow enforce it and we showed them
look you can do something like this on
chain and we
brought that in we trialed it for like a
month or two period
and then we gathered all information
from that to show you know how much this
was affecting customers and our business
and everything
went back to the regulator and said look
you're stifling innovation for us here
and creativity so
if you're going to continue to do that
we're going to move and we're going to
go elsewhere
um so at that point they were happy to
drop it we tried it we proved it just
didn't work and it would have killed the
business
and they allowed us to open they'll
remove that rule and carry on as the
rest of the world was
and so i think that was definitely
that's a a
a lesson for um i think the us at the
minute as well if the u.s continue with
the
infrastructure bill and uh don't make
amendments the instructor bill doesn't
come into play until 2023
um okay gets passed um but obviously
there can be amendments made
from now until then that they'll
hopefully try and get through but if
they don't get any through
then they're going to see a mass exodus
of companies
individuals um leaving the u.s to go
elsewhere to develop
um because it won't make bitcoin illegal
but it makes
um effective everything around it
difficult yeah
and it's just not worth it to the
individual to and if they want to
continue working on it or continue
working the company or d5 or software
side they're going to move and
go to you know another country that is
friendly to
crypto um so yeah it's at the detriment
of the us
and introducing this really yeah i
totally agree with you i think
that's the thing because cryptocurrency
is inevitable to me
bitcoin is inevitable this entire
decentralized space is inevitable you
know even if we're talking about like
decentralized applications you know just
even down to that and surely the us
would want to be at the forefront of it
you know like they're at the forefront
of everything um
so yeah but that's a really interesting
story actually you know that you um
you went back to the regulators and you
said look this is just not practical and
they were happy to let that go i think
that's actually pretty amazing
yeah i think it was just it's kind of is
communicating with them and
showing the real world example that we
we had to trial it for a couple of
months to prove that you know this would
have killed the business
um and unfortunately we had to see it at
the time and it did stifle it and slow
it down and
the amount of customer support issues
that people were having they didn't
understand it was new technology it just
didn't work
and i think even today that's still that
same process would still struggle to
work so
um it's certainly there's lots of work
to do it's
it is just education that the industry
as a whole is new
technology is new and regulators are not
experts at these things and they need
the help just as much as everybody else
does as long as they're willing to
accept the help and
and the advice to take on and hopefully
um
introduce that in a workable manner for
all the companies and
individuals around yeah i mean
you know just speaking of um they need
help and things like that
i think was elizabeth warren that sort
of used bitcoin a doge in the same
sentence
um you know i love i love a bit of doge
like i find it so funny like
you know it's just funny but you just
can't compare the two you know
um no we we actually so we felt we we
launched
coin corner back in 2014 with dogecoin
did you
yeah we had bitcoin litecoin dogecoin i
think it was
um but that was because you know it just
launched it was a popular thing at that
time and we were just launching and you
kind of just go with that
and it was early days um but yeah it's
it's you can't
it's just not a not a fair comparison um
of the two
um yeah no so given
given all of this uh you know
infrastructure bill we've got
um you know uh the fca in the uk
cracking down on cryptocurrency
exchanges the infrastructure bill like i
said despite all of this
a bitcoin is moving which is so exciting
um i think
right now i'm looking on finance and
it's at forty five thousand nine hundred
dollars so it's just under 46k
very exciting um so i want to get your
thoughts on the markets you know
we had that crash everybody thought that
was it
china won put it as bluntly as that
um do you think we're getting it is this
the second wave is this
the second wave of the bull market what
do you think
yeah i think so i think this um i've
kind of been
uh hinting eye on on twitter for a while
with um i think
some of the guys that doing the on chain
analysis side yeah
he's really good really good comparisons
um i think the
for the most part most of it kind of
correlates and
lines up with the history the historic
2013 and 2017 sort of runs
you see a bit of a rise we have a bit of
down time and accumulation period and
then we start to go again for a second
part of
the ball run the ball room generally
lasts him for you know between 12 to 18
months
um time periods um with the real
spike probably um if history's to go
from it would you know be coming sort of
again november december time similar
sort of time periods uh this year
um so i can imagine at the minute the
way we've seen it from history then
yes second spike looks like it'd be
coming uh the second run looks like it'd
be coming
um and heading any time now from towards
the end of the year really
um for a uh a sort of uh bull run high
um the
so yes surely i've tried not to uh
can't give investment advice i haven't
asked
you as generic as possible here
um so yeah i think that's definitely
coming
um the the one thing the one difference
um at the minute from 2017 and 2013 that
we're seeing today
is the bitcoin leaving exchanges
so right the bitcoin actually on the
exchanges has been in a downwards
trend now for uh i think it's going up
nearly two years
18 months towards two years now um
that is always a metric that people do
pay attention to and keep an eye on um
and that's what you mean in people are
buying bitcoin on the exchange
withdrawing it to their
cold storage will withdraw into the
personal wallets elsewhere
with that downward trend we've never
seen that in 11 years of bitcoin's life
and this is the first time this is
happening
i appreciate those there's arguments
that say well you know there's more
bitcoin in circulation now which is why
this we're going on the downward trend
um or um there's more there's better
infrastructure in terms of
uh cold storage devices and things like
that which is more which are more
user-friendly so people don't have to
hold on exchanges
and they can withdraw it and keep it in
a user-friendly manner and so there is
argue count
i guess counter arguments to certain
things uh um but i think generally this
downward trend that we're seeing
will create um a lack of liquidity on
the exchanges
in terms of training so one when we talk
about um
sometimes put this out on twitter and
you get a lot of people asking you know
what does this mean
um so the the lack of liquidity on
exchanges as it's coming off
as the price starts to move again and
it's moving quickly
there's not enough depth to hold up
certain um
ranges so all of a sudden you may see
massive movements which we we have
already seen this year we saw big you
know i think one day was
um did we have a 10k a day i think one
day um 10 000
movement in day you know that
historically
was yeah yeah i think we had one day
which was um
a few months ago right yeah yeah yeah it
could have been after the elon
uh elongate uh the elon candle yeah
yeah i think it was um due to that um
but that was like you know
the year before we weren't even at ten
thousand dollars now
yes and thousand dollar movements in a
day so you know this is natural and this
will happen and you know
going forwards ten thousand dollar
movements in a day
might start to become more natural you
know if we're at two hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin then
ten thousand dollars in a day is
insignificant compared to where we are
now
um so so on that point i have to ask you
then because
um people always talk about this um and
i get this a lot on tick tocks i'm
always like pushing bitcoin on tick tock
obviously
um and people are always saying to me
what kind of currency is that right
if it can move 10 grand in a day what
kind of currency is that
what do you say to that it depends on it
depends on the value
of the currency at the time i guess um
yes
yeah yeah yeah um i mean if
if bitcoin's worth a million dollars and
it moves ten thousand dollars a day
it's tiny it's it's negligible movement
it's nothing um
so i appreciate the minute it's less for
me would focus on the percentage
movement rather than the
value movement um the percentage
movement is still big especially when on
the ten thousand day
um you know it's a twenty two percent of
whether it was movement i kind of figure
um so that is still a big movement for a
currency and i think
people need to appreciate at the minute
bitcoin is
still in its infancy and it's in um
i guess the way i see a lot of people
see that is bitcoin initially was
you know this experimental technology
and it kind of grew eventually into
a speculative asset as as kind of where
we're going to now in an investment
um eventually obviously we're moving now
people are treating it as a store of
value a long-term savings
angle um and then eventually longer term
it'll start to become
as the volatility reduces it will start
to become more of a usable currency at
that level
you know currencies are volatile every
single day around the world that they're
trading backwards us dollar to gbp you
to euro everything else
they're all moving and they're still
volatile between themselves
it's just that i guess the country
you're in if you're uk you're using gbp
you're you're not paying attention to
the gbp against you the dollar or the
euro or anything like that because
it doesn't affect your everyday life
whereas with bitcoin you are comparing
it because it's a new currency
um so there's a slight different
mentality i guess you have to look at
and think about
um when you're talking about the
currency movements and prices
uh a simple question to back to some of
them might be okay so what did the
uh pound move against the dollar today
then if if you think bitcoin's volatile
and nobody has a clue because they don't
really pay attention to that
um but it doesn't mean you know but i
just do you know no idea
no idea who cares it's much smaller
percentage movements than bitcoin is
right now
and that's because there's markets in
place and
um world global economies that have been
around now for however many
decades centuries and they've um created
some sort of stability in the markets
and that will happen with bitcoin over
time but we're still early and it does
take time for that to happen
um so yeah there's no short answer to
that question i think it's
quite a long-winded answer uh i think
for the most part
yeah no i'm with you i think you know
ultimately we have to appreciate that it
is only a 12-year-old asset
and give it time everything
you know it's it's i look at it like a
baby like babies are volatile
babies are screaming babies are crying
doesn't mean they're not going to grow
up to be excellent things you know
still doing excellent things right now
that's not fair look at it
um but this bull market is interesting
because you know
when we saw el salvador for example um
you know recognize bitcoin as legal
tender that's when bitcoin was low
um and all the there was a lot of
bullish news coming out and it still
didn't manage to drive up the price
um now it's just sort of going i i
wouldn't say anything is necessarily
sparked i would say this is the most
bearish from a let's say like a
sentiment and kind of like a
like a news standpoint this is the most
bearish time that we're in given all
this regulation and all this uncertainty
and yet it's it's the price is going so
what
would you say is driving the price right
now
um all the things you've just mentioned
there with the el salvador okay
delayed reaction yeah yeah um
that's the the momentum takes it takes
time for momentum to build up
and um we've seen that over even 2020
you know we had a
from the financial crash back in march
um we then had uh the harvin
and then we had this this build up
through the whole of 2020 of the price
slowly grinding up the sentiment
changing towards bitcoin
um that takes time and we got to a stage
where we got towards the end of the year
at 29
000 i think we were um and then the new
year came
and it started to really ramp up and
start to move and then obviously we have
the spike and we die down again and
we're back to then accumulation period
momentum building
um the good news is still coming but it
it takes time for
you know we're in we i think we pay
attention to the industry far more than
um
the most most people out there in the
world so you know we're living it day in
day out so when we see this news we're
like
why is nobody reacting to it but you
know then go outside
our bubble and talk to people and
sometimes that you know they're like
they don't they're not even aware of
like elon musk accepting or tesla
accepting bitcoin and
um they're not aware of them things
until you start telling people
even the paypal news of paypal now
having bitcoin on the platform
you know people outside of the industry
still don't even
know that and they're not aware of that
um so
these things do take time and the the
momentum and the positivity and the
positive momentum that takes time to
build up
and so i think there's combinations of a
variety of things that the momentum
there from
the the external the retail market the
world um
there's accumulation phases that
obviously we're going through the mining
at the halving still from just 15. still
you think still yeah it's all going to
take effect so usually
um the again going back from history
so don't don't say my word for this one
but if you look back in history
and 2013 2017 and the harvin during them
time periods and the bull markets
uh it takes between i think it's uh 12
to
15 about 15 months on average um
around 15 months to go from when the
harvin was to the next cycles all-time
high
so you would imagine then the next
all-time high comes for us around
september october
which is what i'm saying now which is
yeah this year um because that's kind of
like 15 months
to 18 months after the harvan um so the
harbin takes time to kick in
and the effect to happen um so there's a
combination of so many things i think
around the world we've got regulation
slowly coming in we've got
um the likes of paypal you've got banks
getting involved you've got
everybody now you've got funds etfs are
starting to hopefully
um sort of break a little bit of
movement there in the us as well and i
know further afield we've already
started to see
etfs popping up and there all that side
of things is
will naturally start to move the price
but they take time and then they will
take time
you can see the etfs in the us have been
trying to get through for
years three four years now i think it is
yeah i still haven't got the first one
through but you know the move there is
movement
um so yeah it it takes time and it's a
slow
long-term um look or view of the world
rather than
um the short term trying to hope it's
going to go to 200 000
next week you know you've got to take
the long-term strategy of these things
appreciating everybody wants to do that
and everyone wants to make a quick book
in that angle which is a completely
different
um argument or view of it
um so yeah give it give it time i think
we'll be getting there
yeah it it's pretty crazy i mean it's
just constantly
more and more news you know and more and
more bullish news
which would you know really give the
industry more
credit and you know with incredible
players like like paypal you know
tesla and all these players it really
gives the industry so much more
credibility
especially when you're trying to speak
to people outside of our bubbles you put
it um
but what's always really interesting to
me is that is the tribalism but i won't
get into that really it's more just like
where we are going and what let's just
say the internet in general is going to
be built on
uh because some people say bitcoin some
people say ethereum and there's that
real kind of divide between the two i
know that you are
quite there i don't think okay okay i'm
not gonna call you
anything but i know you lean more
towards the bitcoin side of things
i'm being polite i'm being nice no i'm
joking look like i think you know you
lean towards
the bitcoin side of things so from your
opinion do you really think that
what is being built on eth right like
defy dapps all of this stuff
because that stuff is inevitable that's
coming will it really be built on
bitcoin
can it be um i think that
there's so many different arguments um i
for me as i've talked about earlier on
with bitcoin being the focus you know
i'm trying to focus on on bitcoin sound
money and trying to create
um the the future of where i see bitcoin
going there
there ethereum is created to be a
completely different product and
different
um a different niche a different market
and so they're going after a completely
different industry however they have
tried to pivot a number of times and now
they're trying to call themselves
ultrasound money i think was the latest
one
oh i didn't see that that's cheeky i
didn't see that one
but you know it's they've i mean they've
changed their monetary policy
a number of times over the years due to
they think it should change the x y and
z and they're just automatically
changing it
and you know bitcoins has never been
changed and that's for me
um the solid foundation of what you're
building on so building products on a
solid foundation is is required
and having this the not necessarily even
just the security aspects of it but you
know the
in terms of mine and hash rates but in
terms of um you're building on something
that you know
so ingrained into the the community and
to the world that
you know 21 million bitcoins are not
he's never going to change and
and that's it and the mining and the um
new bitcoin coming in circulation is
never going to change and you know
that monetary policy you know how it's
it's coming out whereas with
other coins and ethereum and so on you
know because they've chopped and changed
and they move around it becomes
difficult to
for me i wouldn't be building something
i wouldn't be building my business and
my business model on top of something
that could change
at the drop of a hat because one guy
says so um
so it it doesn't make sense from a
business model perspective
or a long-term business model
perspective to build on them platforms
like ethereum and so on
yet um a lot of what we're seeing on
ethereum is
i guess uh research r d
trial and error people are trying
various things um we've had
uh crypto kitties back in 2017 i think
that was we've had yeah
um obviously the nfts we've got all the
d5 but
um you're seeing all the the rug pulls
as people call it
um with various things once you know
it's becoming
ethereum was as whatever's hot topic the
wild west
building yeah they were building on
ethereum the hot topic side of it so the
tokens was
initially the sort of thing and then um
obviously
moving on to uh the cryptokitties and
the games and things that crash the
the network and it can't scale in the
way that it needs to to
to create these things um i'm trying not
to go into
too much detail in trying to stay high
level but um
the the short of it i think for me
um with ether i try not to
uh abuse anyone building things because
there's lots of genuine people out there
building
um the products of trying to build
products and do appreciate that but
there's also a lot of like you say there
the wild west where
yeah um people are building for a
short-term gain on something that they
know has not really got long-term
viability but they build it anyway to
throw it out there
have a pre-mine of whatever and run away
with some money um
bitcoin because people are not doing
that and people are building
genuine sustainable products and real
world
um use cases we call it they don't have
the
budget and the market money they haven't
done an ico and they haven't done these
things so they don't have that marketing
budget to go and sell um
to the public so the public with the
ethereum tokens and so on you've got
this
ico money and you go in and raise x
amount x y and z
i mean we've seen history 98 we're like
of icos now we're dead i think uh well i
didn't know um
i think it was i think it was nassau 99
points something percent of
icos now are all shut down um don't
quote me on that
google and clarify um but it is a big
percentage so
you can see they know they've raised
money they've thrown marketing out there
people have come in
the founders have probably done very
well for themselves and they the
product projects shut down and disappear
and you know that happens in the real
world and business and everything as
well but
this was a little bit more wild west
than that i guess um
whereas with bitcoin people are building
obviously with lightning and even
liquid and um you see them
um impervious at layer three now and
you've got um
yeah the sort of uh sphinx chat and
things you know people are building them
things without
even most of the world don't seem to
realize but you know that's where for me
the real innovation is happening and
people are creating
real world products and real world use
cases like
lightning now being able to be used for
el salvador yeah
without lightning being there then el
salvador would have never adopted it
um but without bitcoin being the strong
foundation that it is with
the hash rates and the uh long-term
sustainability trustability of the code
base and
not changing monetary policy and things
that is what gives
el salvador comfort that they can use
lightning built on top of bitcoin and
drive that way
so yeah if i was going to build any form
of
layers whether that's defile or any
other layers on top of
one of these i would be looking at a
long term personally i would be looking
at a long term
strategy and for the business model i'm
looking to create and for me that would
be building it on
bitcoin yeah um maybe not no i
understand
no i i understand i understand i think
for me personally everything is so new
so i'm yet to see how everything plays
out definitely have an open mind about
everything
um but i hear you um and you know you
mentioned el salvador there and
that just sort of makes me just sparks
my brain a bit about
again just regulations and all the
hostility towards it and
just makes me laugh really you know like
a country have tried to do something
really incredible for themselves you
know if you look on google and it says
what's their currency it says us dollar
and bitcoin yeah they've got so much
so much hostility so um i know obviously
we're
tight for time now but like just just
want to get your thoughts really why do
you think they
they receive so much hostility um
elsewhere like yeah um
i don't know from i guess yeah from the
imf and that side i guess that would be
expected
um that's um
a us perspective el salvador used their
currency as their primary currency
um and then anything like they're
looking to move to bitcoin from the us
dollar or that they've introduced
bitcoin alongside the us dollar that
threatens the u.s
dollar and that threatens the u.s power
and their control
um so they're gonna get it was it was um
inevitable that they would get the um
backlash from the us
and uh even the imf um and i'm sure
other
places will give them a kick along the
way as well and that's something that
they're gonna have to deal with and then
they should
will have known that from day one when
they set out to do that um
i know there was a little bit small
parts of backlash i think from
public um i saw some of the uh was it in
el salvador they were
um protesting i think for to not have
bitcoin as their currency
really i didn't see that i think there
was
it was made out to be something more
than i think it was because there was
only i think
there was a picture of a couple of
people doing it and then i think
somebody took a picture further back and
there was like
you know 15 people actually protesting
not like thousands
made out so i don't think it was much
more than that um
but yeah it's it's changed it's new uh
yeah
the world disappeared i'm still here my
camera shuts off after 20 minutes i
don't know why it does that
okay um yeah it's something new
something that the world's
um trying to get to grips with and the
public are trying to get to grips with
uh the media is still spinning things
about you know
negative conceptions of bitcoin of uh
criminal activity and money laundering
and it's anonymous and all these sort of
things
so with all that in mind you know the
public outside of
our industry i'll see in mainstream
media talking about these things and
talking about the negative side of
bitcoin and
you know the energy usage and all these
things so
without the public really going off and
doing their own education on it and
their own learning
they are just going to take in what
they're seeing in the media and they're
going to
take that um perception of bitcoin of
what that is and they're going to spin
that and they're going to go and protest
because
they've seen that it you know pollutes
the earth and destroys
it boils the oceans and and so on um
which obviously we know is not true but
um media unfortunately uh helped drive
that
i think that's just the way it is and
it's gonna be the way it is with any new
technology or any new movements
especially in financial side yeah and
especially with something which poses
such an inherent threat i mean i was
talking to somebody the other day about
donald trump because apparently he might
run for uh president again in 2024 and
you know he's supposedly anti-bitcoin
apparently apparently i had i don't know
i don't i don't think he's announced it
but i think
that was just like a conversation that
he could run and i was like well that's
quite exciting
for many reasons but anyway um so
apparently
um people say oh no we don't we want we
there kind of get my words out we
wouldn't want him because he's not good
for bitcoin but i don't think that it's
like
he's not good for bitcoin i just think
he's like a us dollar
maximalist and they understand the
threat that it poses
yep yeah there's there's a i think
there's a documentary that's flagged up
to the team actually to watch the
um petrol is it petrodollar documentary
or something oh i've heard of it
i've heard of it yeah it's just it's
only i don't know who's done it i think
someone in our industry has actually
created it but um i was going to have a
watch of that tonight at some point
um just it's only 30 i think it's like
30 minutes long um so it's not too bad
but
yeah i'm imagining that's going to
highlight a lot of that side of
how the us dollar has its um dominance
and the war side and oil and everything
else so yeah be interesting watch maybe
yeah 100 i'll check that out but just
finally um i'd love to hear your opinion
on where you see the space in five years
and i say five years because five years
isn't that far away
bitcoin is guaranteed to be booming in
my opinion um
but you know what's the next hype but
we've had d5 had nfts
you know this year we've had
institutional investors jumping in
and you know countries making it legal
tender what's like the crux of in five
years time what can you imagine
um anyone's guess these days
anyone's getting um yeah i think
from an industry perspective it's
difficult to say obviously we've seen
with the
uh the nfts and the icos and the
altcoins and tokens and
you know all that sort of the defy side
and so on that
is potentially literally literally
anyone's guess i know the
the uh road maps we call it of like
ethereum you know they're trying to
bring
a lot of the financial world onto um the
platform as such there which
you know maybe that'll happen we'll see
how that goes um
with the the bitcoin side um a big part
of
going forward for me and my focus um
going forwards over these next five
years
uh is that the layers kind of built on
top of bitcoin which we're seeing so
your layer twos with lightning
and starting to introduce lightning into
uh more of a real world environments and
use cases whether that's just for
payments whether that's
um the sphinx chart is a great example
one so like
you know everyone's got whatsapp what is
that explain that to me
the sphinx chat is the spec like
whatsapp or telegram but it's
it's every message you send to somebody
is a lightning transaction
so it means that it's encrypted end to
end so there's only you and the
recipient that can read that message
so it's kind of like a decentralized
whatsapp chat
built on bitcoin yeah and it's using all
the lightning invoice payments to
actually communicate and transact and
uh talk to each other um so that's like
one of the first examples of
of that side we've seen the
tlv which was a kind of a an example
thing from
uh just jaeger i think it's called um
so he was again lightning kind of
developer and
he created tlv shop which was a
website but you all of the payments and
the products and everything
and your user account was kind of
controlled and transacted by lightning
so
you wanted to buy a product on the
website you scan the qr code
um for the to make the payment by
lightning and when you make that
payment in the invoice and the message
that you're sending across to the shop
you include your name and your address
and all the details
so it means that the your
email address your password nothing like
that needs to be saved on
um within the website with the
e-commerce company um you don't even
need to store your
delivery address because all that's in
the lightning invoice and goes across to
them
uh which can obviously be deleted and so
on but um
that starts to remove away obviously
credit cards and cards are
mass use online on online shops and
paying um and they're obviously arrive
for
fraud and credit card for all the things
so people get cards stolen
websites get compromised and your
details are leaked so
it's starting to start effectively move
away but what we call pci compliance in
the card world so that's
every website that accepts cards
theoretically has to be pci compliant
and go through all these checks if you
don't accept credit cards but you just
have
bitcoin lightning payments and so on
then you can move the pci compliance
um aspects away from your your company
um so you don't need to even
uh deal with that side of it so i think
over the next five years we're going to
start to see
um various sectors or various products
and
and features being slowly disrupted by
lightning and the layer twos
uh and hopefully the layer threes as
well um coming soon which
layer three is um kind of still
under wraps for the most part but
there's quite a few little projects now
starting to pop up which is um
really interesting when i say layer
three that's just built on top of
lightning
and so you've got bitcoin layer one
lightning your layer two and then you've
got layer three which is built on top of
lining
um which will start to appear very soon
oh i think it's so exciting i for one
really hope
um we see more lightning adoption and
more education about lightning
because more people just need to be
using it to make the whole experience so
much easier
instant fearless almost um and
i think that will change the narrative
around bitcoin so much more especially
because a lot of the criticism is often
you know that it can't scale
um i feel lightning needs to prove
itself
on a on a large scale to kind of shut
that down
um as well yeah
yeah hopefully el salvador does that for
lightning and proves that you know it
works at a scale so
um fingers crossed that'll go smoothly
we'll see el salvador is a test i mean
it is a test you know
that's what it is isn't it um but fine
just finally danny um
what can what are the new updates we can
expect with coin corner you know where
can people find you
um just plug yourself
and shamelessly plug ourselves um so
yeah
coincorner.com um on twitter as well
most of the teams on a lot of the teams
on twitter um coincon and danny
um you got molly zach dave everyone else
on there
um you uh new stuff new new
side of things coming from corner this
year um we
um do have cards coming soon um
oh cards eventually we're still um
in in progress with them um so they
should be coming soon um
we have hopefully a new i'll say
hopefully we do have a new app coming
soon as well um
the apps we do have an app at the minute
but um
in need of a re-haul um
and i think one of the big things again
uh we're continuing to focus on
on the bitcoin side um and the cash back
and and the auto buys and things like
the features we already have we're
starting to try and
um help i guess make them more
user-friendly and help on board people
like like yourself
um trying to cash back out it's
something that a lot of the world don't
seem to know we've got there still and
it's trying to
kind of push that out and help show
people what we have
um in a nice easy cashback absolutely
grateful
do your shopping online get bitcoin back
for percentage of whatever you shop
um and obviously that's just over time
adding an adding and it's like a
savings account effectively for a long
term um
strategy so dca and while shopping
dca and more shopping i love that i'm so
excited about the cards i love
a good crypto card like i have too many
i love them
all and they're they're all just
slightly different you know whether it's
earning interest or if it's cash back or
you know they're all really cool um but
yeah i want to thank you so much for
coming on it's been really really
interesting learning more about um you
know what you guys are up to
and just getting your perspective on the
markets right now because you know it's
it's a confusing time some people say
they know what's going on some people
have no idea
so it's always good to understand more
yeah i have no idea
i said this the other day i was like i
was like do you know what if somebody
tells me that they
actually know i don't believe them
yeah officially thank you for having me
on there appreciate it
yeah absolutely and thank you so much
for my sponsors block by luno and
compass mining and of course icon plus
capital guys don't forget to tune
in next week for another brilliant guest
we'll see you then bye